oh where to start on these elections for
today i wish they hadn't chosen these
for parents weekend whoever wrote the
lectionary clearly did not have parents
weekend in mind because these are some
tough words we're approaching that time
of year they head into the second half
of the Gospel of Mark Jesus turns his
eyes towards Jerusalem and things go bad
from there on down hat and Jesus's words
get tougher and tougher and tougher and
what better word could they have for
parents weekend than this gospel from
mark which says children if you leave
your mother and your father and your
sisters and brothers leave them behind
turn your back you'll be rewarded 100
fold that's the message you want to hear
right and I know the other part also
made you wonder a little bit where Jesus
turns to the young not young man in the
mark but the man and says all you lack
is one simple thing sell all you have
and give to the poor and follow me how
did you like us to preach that to your
children I know that's one of your worst
worries is exactly that kind of thing so
we've got hard messages today but what I
want to focus on as an entry into these
three great scriptures from Amos from
Hebrews and from the Gospel of Mark it's
just one simple question which is who do
you let criticize you and under what
circumstances we all get criticized but
there are some people we let criticize
us because we trust them because we know
them because they have authority to
criticize us and there other people we
get offended we don't listen we just put
it off I think that applies to our
scriptures today because Jesus is
criticizing just a little bit and I want
us to think about whether we let him
criticize us or not and then there's
this incredible warning warning yeah
warning i guess is the right word about
from the book of Hebrews it says indeed
the Word of God is living and
div it's probably not talking about
Jesus probably talking about the word
the teaching of God it's sharper than
any two-edged sword piercing until it
divides soul from spirit joints from
marrow it is able to judge the thoughts
of the intention and attentions of the
heart and before it no creature is
concealed but all are naked and laid
bare to the eyes of the one to whom we
must render an account happy thoughts
the Word of God is like a two-edged
sword that pierces into us I know people
come to church for happy moments for
uplift for joy for those happy clappy
songs but the Word of God sometimes is
really tough and it's tough right now
and it's tough in these passages not
because God wants to depress us not
because God wants to condemn us but as
we see in this story from mark it's very
simple that in order for us to enter the
kingdom of God we may have to change
some things God wants us in the kingdom
with him God wants us to have eternal
life eternal happiness and so God
sometimes has to point out things I
don't know how you feel about your
parents pointing out things about you
students and all our members every time
I went home to visit my father over 30
years whatever he said sounded like
critique if he said I'd gained weight I
thought he was saying I was fat if he
said I'd lost weight I thought he was
saying I wasn't taking care of myself
whatever he said it came across as some
kind of critique of me and I don't know
about you parents but you may have had
the experience of your children coming
home and noticing things that they never
noticed before like every inconsistent
thing you've ever done
life everything you taught that you
didn't quite live up to in daily
practice and sometimes students will
come home with a list I had long lists
for my parents going back ten years of
everything they'd ever done but didn't
quite live up to exactly what they
taught me criticism is really hard to
take and I found this great story that I
thought was an entry into this and I'm
and I'm going to try and be brief today
but we never know when I start preaching
and it was a little article in the
quotes called The Chronicle of Higher
Education which is a newspaper for
college and it was written by the
director of a Writing Center at a small
liberal arts college I think it just
talks about our culture and how we
respond to criticism and this is how it
begins the man is writing about a
student and he says Devin's face flushed
his lips began to quiver a tear formed
in the corner of his right eye and he
wiped it away with the back of his hand
before hastily shoving his paper which
he had shown me into his book and
standing up and saying I'm leaving now
Devin who was around 18 and had walked
into the Writing Center I direct wanted
to see if the paper he'd written for
freshman composition made sense and I
was pushing him to identify the
rhetorical elements like the purpose and
value of the newspaper article he'd
written about and answer questions like
was the article coherent and
well-written did the author develop his
argument fully and the article he was
commenting on was very strong and
opinionated and I thought the purpose
was to entertain and instruct and the
value was high Devin however said he was
offended personally by the article and
that was the thrust of his paper and I
just flat-out told him he couldn't just
say that in an academic paper his
offense didn't count he could phone his
mother and tell her how offensive the
article was where he could write to the
author himself and tell him but critical
analysis while it may begin with emotion
is a practice that requires keen
observation
sharp reflection cold-hearted logic
crisp reasoning I see discernment and
cool evaluation and when I explained
this to Devan he reached for the Kleenex
and after his hasty exit I spent a few
minutes feeling sort of strange about
this and then I wrote him an e pology I
told him that I sensed he was upset and
I was sorry if I offended him I further
explained that as the college writing
centers director I see my primary
mission as treating all individuals with
respect which means providing a
student-friendly non-threatening
environment where they can practice
their writing skills and develop into
critical thinkers quite unexpectedly
Devon replied with a long explanation
the general point of which was my mother
has told me now that all my ideas are
good and right I was stunned and so ends
the section of the article we have an
exquisite sensitivity these days so many
of us and I'm not pinning this on the
students it's almost everybody I know in
our culture it's it's it's this idea
that if I'm offended if I'm hurt if what
you say critiques a part of me that it's
not something to be coldly or rationally
worked out it's not something that I can
learn from it's a personal attack but I
think Christian faith says that Jesus
looks at us she does in this Gospel
story think about this Gospel story
again and think about it in light of
this story of the young man in this
story this man comes to Jesus just like
every other healing and miracle story in
the Gospel of Mark we've been through 20
of them so far this year people the man
rushes up he kneels at Jesus's feet and
he says what do I need to do just like
the lepers just like the parents who
want their children to be healed just
like the blind and the lame all of whom
have had mirror
performed he rushes up to Jesus he
kneels down at his feet me says what do
I have to do and Jesus says well you
have to follow these rules he says ok
I've done all that and it says and this
is the key word in the passage Jesus
looked at him and loved him he looked at
him and he saw right through him he saw
what he needed he saw who he was he saw
everything that was going on in his life
just by looking at him he knew what was
holding him back he knew what was
pushing him forward he knew what had him
stuck he knew what the possibilities
were he looked at him he loved him and
he said but there's one thing you lack
just one little thing it's just like the
healing stories Jesus says go and wash
in the stream go and wash in the pool do
something do this stand up move around
she's always give some kind of direction
to the person he's healing and to this
man he just says on one little thing you
have to do sell all you have give it to
the poor and follow me and it's the only
story in mark where the invitation to
discipleship is rejected the man goes
away grieving for he has many
possessions it's really hard to know
that God might have something other than
unconditional love for us we believe
deeply that our God the God we know in
Jesus Christ loves us unconditionally
and has given his life for us but that
doesn't mean Jesus is going to lie to us
either he looks at us He loves us and he
sees what stands between us in the
kingdom of God because Jesus wants us to
join doesn't want the kingdom to start
without us being there and sometimes he
has to say there's this small part of
your life that needs to change before
you can be a part of the celebration of
justice and healing that's going to come
there is this little piece that needs to
change it's really hard to hear but the
book of Hebrews again makes it very
clear that though the Word of God cuts
like a knife it also says that Jesus has
been there before us has suffered
through everything we've suffered
through understands every temptation
understands even greed understands every
negative emotion and urge that we have
and forgives us for it and says approach
the throne of mercy with boldness at the
end of the story and mark the healing
story the man goes away sad Jesus in the
dot and the disciples have this dialogue
and I see who can be saved this is
terrible you know rich people can't be
saved they're all these conditions how
can we possibly work this and he says
with mortals nothing can be done sorry
but with God all things are possible
this sounds like such a condemnation go
sell all you have give to the poor and
follow me and the man doesn't do it it
goes away but we never know what happens
that's the funny thing about this story
never tells us what happens to the rich
man I like to think Jesus wants
everybody in the kingdom Jesus gonna
find a way I think maybe a month maybe a
year maybe 10 years maybe 20 years this
man changed his attitude to his wealth
sold it gave it away and became a new
person it's possible for any of us any
time we can approach the throne of grace
with boldness because he's been there
before us amen